what's scary this time of year besides
doing stuff like that
haunted house lines and wait times but
with new safety protocols in place
everyone gets the vip experience this
year at hotel fear
ain't that right rocky
yeah and um so as i said earlier in the
show i was looking for a room and
unfortunately they had one and
room for one yeah room for one and i i
hear it's a vip experience
it's just for you of course okay let's
go guys come see
what i'm working with in here we are at
hotel fear at meadows mall
and uh i have to tell you i'm i'm
scared i'm actually genuinely scared
right now rich you are the owner of this
beautiful place
um tell us how you're how you're
actually doing these walk-through
haunted houses
during covet as if times could get
scarier
yes well we started working on our covet
plan back in
may when we realized that something was
going to have to happen
right so we started that we dealt with
other amusement parks and haunted houses
and what they were doing we all kind of
got together and put plans
submitted them back in july so we could
always kind of socially distance in the
haunt anyway because we
did keep space between our groups okay
let's walk let's walk
we'll see you later i'll see i'll see
you later girlfriend
so so that part wasn't as as hard we
knew we could we already had spaces so
we just needed to
now deal with uh you know places where
actors were going to test the hardest
part is outside
right in that case we have we have an
outdoor queuing area which helps us
but then they also we had to go to a
time ticketing system so by doing time
ticketing
then uh that keeps that limited amount
of people here so that's why we say
everyone ends up with a vip experience
because normally
you get to halloween you've got two
three hour wait in line exactly
exactly this we're only allowing the
people in that time segment on the
property so you have to wait in your
card
until you get a text message that says
you can go on the property
okay then you have your temperature
taken you sign your waivers
uh you get your hand sanitized before
all of them and then you go through the
attraction so that's why we keep
everybody social
well thank you so much you guys see
okay guys coming up we're going to show
you the other
the other place you can visit over here
at the meadows mall thanks to this guy
he's nice but i don't know i'm
rethinking it i'm rethinking
it he got us back back to you guys
you got us back in the studio with that
scarecrow my god
i got you too good i'm not alone in here
we're gonna check back in with you
during the 4pm newscast